chers collègues une nouvelle fois nous
mesurons le courage d'un peuple face à
un régime totalitaire depuis plusieurs
semaines le gouvernement chinois voit sa
jeunesse et sa population se soulever
contre sa politique du zéro covid mais
ne nous y trompons pas à travers elle
c'est contre le régime dictatorial
qu'elle se retourne à cela le parti a
répondu en fermant les espaces publics
fermeture des quartiers suppression des
panneaux de signalisation traçage
électronique enfermé pour mieux régner
toujours mais leur courage porte les
fruits pendant plus d'un mois le pouvoir
a annoncé un assouplissement de sa
politique anticoïde la suspension de
l'application des déplacements mais des
annonces toutefois trompeuses l'Europe
doit être ferme et se tenir aux côtés
des Chinois qui manifestent pour leurs
droits les plus fondamentaux et leur
quête de liberté
ce débat doit aussi nous pousser à être
plus ferme face à ce rival systémique
plus ferme dans notre politique
commerciale à travailler pour une plus
grande autonomie dans nos chaînes
d'approvisionnement chers collègues il
est temps pour les dirigeants européens
tous nos dirigeants européens de prendre
uneaniement position en faveur des
Chinois je vous remercie